[inaudible].
All right.
So one of the things that you write about a lot is that the idea of middle class
stagnation is actually wrong.
We hear this all the time.
It from politicians for I think my whole life that I was ever caring about
politics.
It's always that the middle class is shrinking and the extremes are getting
bigger,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But you actually take a different position on that.
Yeah.
This middle class stagnation thesis is stated as if it's an established fact
with no arguments against it.
It's just,
it's just wrong.
Uh,
I think you were born in the mid seventies,
right?
76.
Okay.
So according to this thesis,
it was,
uh,
it was right around that time mid seventies when apologize.
That's okay.
Maybe it was your fault.
Right?
So the American middle class had been chugging along upward hits the mid
seventies,
and then it's been stagnant ever since.
So the ordinary American say,
so goes,
the thesis lived no better than ordinary Americans lived when Gerald Ford was in
the Oval Office.
I didn't think this is crazy.
I mean,
I have,
um,
uh,
unfortunate old enough to remember the bid 1970s.
And although one zone personal experiences shouldn't be the basis for scientific
conclusions,
they're not irrelevant.
They're thinking,
I know I may come from a working class family.
I remember how we lived in the 70s.
I remember what cars were like.
I remember what television was like.
And I want health care was like,
things are a lot better today for,
for ordinary Americans.
And so I number of years ago just started looking into this,
this thesis,
uh,
there are data that you can find that the people who propose this thesis,
point to,
uh,
that that lends some superficial credence to the thesis.
But here are just some of the problems with these data.
Uh,
they,
uh,
adjust for inflation in ways that vastly overestimate the amount of inflation
that we've had since the mid seventies.
So mean vastly under counting the growth in real incomes since the 70s.
A lot of these data,
we'll look at household incomes,
uh,
well,
the SA,
the typical population of the American household has fallen since the mid 1970s.
Today,
it didn't sound like much,
but today it's about 11% lower than it was in 1975.
Uh,
but that's actually pretty significant.
So the same amount of income and a household,
I was spread over fewer people.
And so the individual individual people are,
are,
are richer,
meaning we're just not having as many kids that we're not having as many kids.
We were becoming wealthier so that now,
maybe not in the last 10 years or so,
but for much of this period,
uh,
younger people,
people have been able to move out of their family,
their parents homes at a younger age and start their households.
Younger,
uh,
older people are able to continue to live by themselves rather than move in with
their,
with their children.
Um,
the quality of goods and the variety of goods and services that Americans,
ordinary Americans have access to today is astonishingly compared to what it was
just 40 years ago.
I actually spend a lot time looking at catalogs from the mid 1970s,
you know,
Sears Roebuck catalogs and then you can look at,
sears.com today and you can look at the prices that we charge back.
They of course,
nominally they will lower,
but then you just take those prices and you divide them by the wage that the
average American earn back then.
They didn't do the same thing for the prices today and divided by the wage of
the average American owns today.
And what you find in almost all cases is that the amount of time it takes to
work in order to earn enough income to buy a pair of jeans,
uh,
assured Oh,
a washer and dryer,
uh,
and an airplane ticket is dramatically less today.
American,
we don't have to work as much today as we did back then in order to get this
things that make our standard of living is high as it is.
So did they just the people that believe in this,
that they just do a great sell job?
I mean,
how did this meme,
how did this idea get out there?
Because you hear this all the time,
everybody,
I mean,
this is one of the few things that you hear on both sides of the aisle.
Yes.
Yeah.
In fact,
I,
uh,
yes,
I think the a lot Paul Krugman says it all says it all the time and I think in a
way kind of backfire and people in the left because they keep saying it and
that,
I believe that's one thing that that helped the drum ups popular support for
Donald Trump,
you know,
middle class American women stagnating.
So let's do something about it.
Let's elect Trump.
There's an interesting psychological thing there because I think maybe most
people think they're in the middle of like,
they probably think it no matter what.
Like they,
if they're not destitute and if they're not,
you know,
worth 20 million bucks,
you probably think basically you're in the middle.
So it's a way of making it about you,
even if it's actually not the case.
You're questioning if I'm not sure exactly,
exactly why it caught by this myth caught on and it has held on with such
tenacity.
Uh,
this myth has been,
gold has been around now for 20 years.
It started in the mid 1990s,
uh,
and it was actually an economist.
He's now at southern Methodist at Smu in Dallas.
He was at the time that an economist at the Dallas Fed guy named Mike Cox,
and he's the first one who really started looking into this.
I said,
well,
let's,
let's look at various measures of living standards.
Let's look at how much ordinary people are consuming today compared to in the
mid seventies.
Let's,
let's,
let's look at what happens when we adjust for income using better inflation.
Adjusters can a,
and w Mike Cox Found,
and I,
I,
my work is derivative of my Cox is that once you start doing this,
this whole middle class stagnation thing just crumbles into dust.
It's just not true.
It's not to say that there are no problems.
It's not to say that the middleclass wouldn't be even wealthier had they're not
had,
they'd been better policies in place.
Whatever you think those policies might be.
But it is to say that is just crazy to believe that an ordinary American or an
ordinary American family in 2018 has a standard of living that is
indistinguishable from that of an ordinary American family in 1975.
Yeah.
Do you know what basically economics look
like if you were considered in the middleclass right now,
like the economics,
are there really like numbers that you look at on both sides and go,
all right,
that's what middleclass is.
Cause I think that's part of the problem.
It is this sort of a morphous term.
Yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
no,
I,
I don't believe that there,
I mean,
you know,
the,
the Census Bureau,
among others,
they will divide household income into quintiles.
Uh,
I don't recall what those numbers are at the moment,
but a common definition is you take the three Middle Quintile,
so you get rid of the top 20%.
You were in the bottom 20% and you have the middle 60% that's,
that's the middle class and upper middle,
middle,
lower,
middle.
Uh,
but the Census Bureau does something interesting from time to time.
It,
so it divides household income and to different categories less than 15,000,
15,000 to 25,000 on and on up to like I think 250,000 and above and attracts
adjusting for inflation.
It tracks household incomes over time.
And you can't in a perverse way,
finding these data that the middle class in America is disappearing,
right?
But it's disappearing into the upper classes.
If you look at the percentage of households in America who are earning,
uh,
in the lowest percentages,
right?
They're shrinking.
The only,
only categories in which the percentage of households in the u s are increasing
or in the upper income levels.
And so actually I think the very lowest,
it might have ticked up a little bit like the blessing 15,000,
but in the great middle,
they have fewer households percentagewise earning in those categories today,
but more earning $100,000 annually.
And above.
And so in one sense,
yes,
it's shrinking,
but it's getting Richard,
there's no evidence that we're getting poor.
There's no evidence that it stagnating.
Yeah.
So we talked a little bit in an ancillary way about taxes,
uh,
earlier.
So I'm not an economist,
but I'm going to lay out what I think is sort of a fair tax system that's
consistent with all the ideals that we've talked about here.
And I want you to [inaudible] either I'm going to be,
either I'm going to blow your mind or you're going to tell me that I'm way off.
So something like this,
this is what I've said a couple times,
is that I'm basically four attacks a flat tax.
You can get rid of exemptions.
Let's say it's about 15% but we can,
we can fiddle with the numbers,
but let's about 15% I would exempt everyone making let's say less than like 40
grand,
maybe even 50 grand.
Oh.
So that they have a little more disposable income that they can do things,
which,
which I think is good for them and good for the economy.
And then just because I'm still,
I still have a little bit of a guilty liberal in me,
I would even be willing to do some sort of progressive tax if you're over say 10
million a year or something like that,
even though I know it's not right,
and I'm sure you can get rid of that by the end of this conversation,
but there's still a piece of me that says that.
But basically saying that for the huge,
vast majority of the country,
15% literal exemptions may be a little trickery on the high end.
I think that's consistent with the
sort of classical liberal idea of minimal involvement and and equality of
opportunity and what you're all paying in and hopefully it would cause a slim or
trim or government.
So,
so some glimmering in your eye.
And so as I said earlier,
I think one of the distinguishing features of an economist has always asks us
compared to what?
Right.
As compared to what we have now.
That that's close to perfect.
All right.
I'll take it right.
As compared to what my actual ideal would be,
given that we're going to have taxes,
it's not quite my ideal.
I would indeed get rid of the,
the,
the progression at the guilty part of me.
I think that still exists,
one of them for,
so the way I look at the way I look at people who earn those kinds of Jane comes
assuming they earn,
and most of them do,
they earn these incomes in the market.
That means that these people are especially good at making life better for
ordinary Americans.
They're especially good at creating jobs.
They're especially good at,
at increasing the value of my 401k.
But what would you say when people say,
but they don't need eight yachts and helicopters and all that?
Uh,
I would say they earned,
it's theirs.
It's not up to me to say what they,
they earn their money.
I can make an argument against that.
I know it's,
there's,
uh,
I mean,
look again,
you know,
if your system is better than what we have now,
but definitely if we're going to have income taxation of flat tax and I'm
willing to have the exemption for the lower lower incomes,
flat tax is the way to go.
Uh,
uh,
not only does it prevent a lot of political chicanery messing with brackets and,
but it,
it's,
it is economically the better system.
Uh,
when you tax all income earning activities at the,
at the same rate,
then the relative prices of different types of labor services stays the same.
When you have progressive taxation,
you create greater distortions in the economy.
And that,
that makes us as an ex,
as,
uh,
as residents of this economy and makes us all a little bit less wealthy than we
otherwise would be because the economy has to deal with these distortions.
So what do we do about spending?
Because at the end of the day,
that seems,
at least when we were talking about this from a government perspective,
that it's really all about spending,
that you can tax out the Wazoo and regardless of whether that tanks,
the economy or,
or fixes it or whatever,
that's almost irrelevant if you just keep spending,
especially because of the amount of debt we have and we're,
we know we're never going to pay it back,
which is why it's probably good that we have a lot of bombs,
but that's a whole lot then that's a whole other discussion.
Um,
you know,
because one day if trying to call in the debt,
we're,
we're in a lot of trouble but,
but how do you reign in spending,
cause this seems to be the thing that all the Trump people,
right,
they all thought he was going to reign in spending this on the opposite pack.
And it's,
it's,
I think it's more than ever before.
It is.
Yeah.
So I think the big questions,
I don't know how to do it.
We can speculate about know changing the constitution,
put in constitutional balanced budget amendments,
constitutional caps on spending.
I'm skeptical of all of those things.
The government has many ways to get around these,
these paper tiger provisions.
Uh,
the problem is the,
is Americans today look to government and they,
and they,
they basically,
you're spending other people's money and so if you're spending other people's
money,
it's easy to spend.
My,
my former colleague,
Russ Roberts had a piece in the Wall Street Journal many years ago entitled
something like,
if you're paying,
I'm having steak.
So imagine,
you know,
imagine that we all go to a restaurant and you know,
the different menu items,
right?
Well,
if you've got a restaurant and you're picking up your part of the tab,
right,
you,
you may order steak,
but that's because it's worthwhile to you and you'll have to pay for it.
Uh,
but you might,
if you have to pay for it,
you might not,
or sick,
you might order a less expensive dish.
But if it's going to be shit,
even as you can be shared right then,
then the bulk of your extra expenditure is shared with the people you're going
to dinner with.
And that's true for every person at the dinner.
And so you wind up with this bizarre circumstance where every person acting
rationally winds up ordering too much wind up asking of the restaurant too much.
We wind up asking if our government too much,
but we have to pay for the resources,
do not fall out of the sky free.
They're coming from somewhere and,
and because we're spending too much,
we're taking resources from where they would be better used and putting them
where really none of us want them to be used,
but we all wind up using them there.
I know you said before that an antidotal story is not,
you know,
proof of a bigger theory,
but as you're saying that,
it reminded,
I don't think I've ever said this publicly,
publicly before at my brother's Bachelor Party when I was a struggling comic and
I had no money.
You know,
I had maybe 50 bucks in my pocket.
I don't know.
I was the best man.
All his friends were in banking and the little areas and they all had money.
Big rollers were at a fancy one.
The one fancy place,
the Borgata in Atlantic city,
the one fancy,
you know,
nice place in Atlantic city and we're sitting around this huge table at a really
super fancy restaurant and,
and all the entrees are 80 9,000 bucks and I'm looking at him,
I'm like,
you know,
what am I going to do here?
I was going to get the chicken for maybe 50 bucks.
He was saying,
and I was sitting with my,
my brother's one friend who also is kind of struggling like I was,
and we're both saying,
all right,
we're going to get the chicken for 50 bucks.
We go around,
everyone's getting steak,
lobster,
steak,
lobster.
It gets to my friend Josh.
He turned,
he's the whole time he's gone and I'm getting the chicken for him that the
waitress says,
what do you want?
He goes,
lobster.
And then I just said,
state like that,
like,
and it's exactly what you're talking about.
You suddenly lose concept of what's in your pocket,
somehow it's going to happen,
right?
And get the bill's going to be shared.
Then the,
the,
the additional cost to you of ordering states adopt a tiny fraction of the
actual additional cost of the steak.
And that's the problem with,
with government today.
We have people in Washington spending other people's money for the benefit of
yet other people.
And when you do that,
you just get too much,
too much spending.
Uh,
we,
we've,
I don't know a better way to say it.
It doesn't sound very economic.
I understand it,
but we've lost the ethic of respecting other people's property.
Once government gets money,
once government officials figure out something that they fancy is,
is,
is good,
and it may or may not really be good,
uh,
which doesn't mean necessarily it's worthwhile,
but maybe a good project.
That doesn't mean that therefore we should go ahead and spend money on it.
Uh,
there's an insufficient connection between the spending and the,
and,
and the,
and the experience of the cost of the resources that go into the spending.
How much are you have this do you think is not an economic problem,
but a political problem so that if a politician was to get this right,
let's say there's some magical politician out there who really understands
economics,
but he knows if he goes to the Senate.
So I suspect grandpa's kind of like this.
I think he basically gets this.
Yeah,
and he does fight the best fight generally that I think he can,
but that these guys want to get reelected and saying to people,
we're going to spend less on you,
even though you know it's,
it's the best thing we can do for you.
Actually.
It's going to free you one day and it's not going to have tank the economy and
make us,
you know,
slaves to a foreign nation and all that.
It just doesn't work politically because it's not the easy answer of give them
more.
I think that's exactly right.
Let's face it.
Each politician has a timeframe that extends to the next election.
Right?
So in the case of members of the house,
that's only two years.
The case with the present,
that's four senators,
six,
that's not a long time frame.
Anything beyond that time frame is irrelevant to that person politically today.
Uh,
or to make it relevant,
that person has to have an ethic that is very rare and unusual among politicians
and people with that.
They,
I think,
tend not to be not to succeed in politics.
Yeah,
a handful do manage to get in,
but very few.
So you have people without that ethic and they're just looking toward the next
election,
which is that most,
again,
only,
you know,
two years away for a house member.
And so if the bill is coming due two and a half years from now,
if the,
if whatever other costs are going to happen to an half years from now,
uh,
or,
or alternatively,
if,
if taking some action that's only going to hit,
it's going to have cost today.
But,
but huge benefits,
no matter how huge,
two years from now,
four years from now,
I'm not gonna take it right because it's,
that will do nothing to get them past that next hurdle,
which is getting elected reelected.
So in a very depressing sense or in a sort of dystopian future sense,
are we in a certain way?
Are we on a pathway to destruction no matter what?
If you think about it,
I mean,
if you take that line of thinking long enough,
right?
So we have a sort of weak political crew dealing in ways that are the reverse of
how economically we can be successful.
Pretty right.
Pretty much always going off the off the cliff.
So I,
despite all that I've said,
I remain optimistic and I'm not,
I'm not sure why.
All right.
Uh,
I feel the same way.
I remain optimistic.
Um,
we,
we still have a respect for private property in the United States.
We were still a very entrepreneurial culture.
Uh,
uh,
we still hold politicians to some,
this is less now,
but there's some level of,
of,
uh,
responsibility.
I say that,
um,
my libertarian friends are going to kill me for saying,
I think there's something,
there's something there.
Yeah.
Uh,
look,
the political problem has always been there.
I think the cost us constitution in the past,
up until about eight years ago maybe did serve more as a constraint that has
largely been shoved away.
Um,
but by and large,
we've still prospered over the past 80 years,
uh,
almost in spite of,
of ourselves.
So this summer is something in the American mindset.
There's something in our gumption,
uh,
and I,
I'm,
I don't want to sound like a mob Rah Rah,
but there's something about this society of ours that remains,
remains relatively open,
remains relatively free property,
private property rights remain relatively secure.
I think we still have something of a,
of a rule of law in,
in place.
And what I've learned in the 40 or so years that I've been pondering these
issues is that a free society is far more robust than I once believed it to be,
which is not to excuse or justify any of the abuses that it takes,
but it's really robust.
And I have no good sense of where the point is.
I don't believe it's indestructable.
Yeah.
But I have no good sense of where the point is where you hit that point and
suddenly things are destined to go into the,
into the gutter.
We may be moving there now.
I have a 21 year old son for his sake.
I certainly hope we're not close to that.
Uh,
but my gosh,
if you look back to the 1930s I think things will be even worse than idealize
governor,
you know,
the,
the trend of government wise than they are today.
And yet we did pretty well.
I,
I'm glad that you just said idealize because one of the things that I focus in
on here is talking about ideas they matter.
That's the whole purpose of what I do.
Do you think that these ideas related to freedom and the individual and laissez
faire capitalism and all of the things that we've discussed here are taking root
again because that's how I started.
You mentioned my interview with Tom and soul right before we started and I sent
it,
and again this is,
I can only tell you what I'm personally feeling and what the feedback I get and
all that.
But I said to Thomas or to Dr Soil,
I said,
do you realize the renaissance of your work is having?
And I think he's kind of,
he's kind of just over it personally.
I think he's proud of his work.
But I think,
yeah,
and of course he shouldn't be.
But I think just on a personal note,
he's kind of like,
yeah,
I've been doing this for a long time and that's great,
but I really sense these things are taking root again,
even though the mainstream media won't let you really believe that and they
still will always elevate the people that are pushing a lot of the more
socialist stuff instead of some people with some.
So getting,
getting back to something I split,
we said earlier,
I think it took a lot of people by surprise in the late 1970s when the ideas for
cutting marginal tax rates dereg deregulation,
uh,
took hold.
And I think that's because people like Milton Friedman,
uh,
my,
my late colleague James Buchanan had been working years earlier in helping to
hire years early to,
to make these ideas sound and accepted and they were in place.
And when the crisis of the 70s hit those ideas had an effect.
Uh,
no one knows the future.
The future's not destined to repeat itself in the way that it did then.
But there are a lot of really good people are,
you're doing great work.
Uh,
there were a lot of really creative young people today push refining these
ideas,
polishing ideas,
presenting them to the general public in new and more interesting ways.
And uh,
maybe it's a hope over maybe the hope over,
I don't know,
hope over reality,
but I actually believe that these ideas are strong.
I think they are appealing and there they are out there.
And while today in May 19,
May,
2018,
uh,
we can't see when they'll take root,
but I think that they will in fact protect us.
That's so that is the optimist in you and I have that too because otherwise,
how could we do what we do?
Right?
I mean if,
if the answer,
if you had looked at me 10 minutes ago and said,
yeah,
pretty much we got to go off the edge,
that one,
then I would have had some of the booze you have about behind me here.
Let's just start drinking right now.
Just wait for Armageddon.
Yeah,
no,
I,
look,
I believe here's something that I did not fully appreciate 20 years ago that I
do appreciate now.
20 years ago I was a more,
a hard nosed economist and now ideas are really irrelevant.
They don't matter that much.
It's,
it's,
you know,
the institutional constraints.
I do think institutional constraints matter.
They're important,
but I've come to see ideas as by far the single most important constraint and
fuel for a society largely affected by the work of Deirdre mccloskey of,
I think you had on,
it was one of my favorite chats that we met you.
You interviewed Deirdre's work has influenced me greatly and her work,
she's not the only one,
but she's done more than any other modern economists to make the case for the
role of ideas.
And I think she's correct.
She's correct in that.
So in that you must be incredibly hopeful then.
Cause I,
I mean I feel the idea revolution.
I'd mentor with Jordan Peterson now and I keeps going up there and saying
there's,
there's the right kind of revolution happening.
We're not killing each other in the streets yet.
And how does that get stopped by an idea revolution?
Yeah.
And you're so,
so at the beginning I mentioned that I came to economics because I was impressed
how economics explained though gasoline shortages in the 1970s so I don't,
if you remember a few years ago,
you know,
gasoline,
Pr Obama was in office,
gasoline prices are rising,
people are complaining.
Here's the importance of idea ideas.
There were,
there were no serious calls,
even the,
in the Obama administration to go back to 1970 style price caps on,
on energy.
I took that as a,
as a,
as a good sign.
That's saying it won't happen in the future.
But I believe the reason that was the case is because the economists who,
Milton Friedman,
among others who explain the devastating roles of price ceilings on energy,
those ideas was still around.
There,
was still out there,
still out there,
and they prevented anyone who would propose such policies seriously from being
taken seriously.
And so that,
that notion of returning to the seventies style price caps just never got a
hearing a few years ago when gasoline prices were high.
So that,
that,
that's one data point that supports,
uh,
our optimism.
Yeah.
That,
that's great.
I mean,
you know,
it's a long game,
right?
I mean that,
that's the point.
It is a long game.
I want to talk a little bit about regulation before,
before we wrap up.
I had a,
you may know him,
the biology professor,
Bret Weinstein,
who's been on the show and he's a,
he's a friend of mine.
Uh,
he made an interesting comment to me the other day.
I think maybe he tweeted out and then we discussed it a little bit about,
well,
if you're,
if you're taking the true libertarian approach and you're against all
regulation,
well are you saying that you want no regulation over the airlines for example,
they have any safety regulations or anything like that and what I,
we didn't have a ton of time to get into the conversation.
I said,
I said Brett,
very quickly,
what I would say is I think airlines are in the business of getting people from
one place to another and they do all their due diligence and if the idea of a
government bureaucrat coming in to make sure that this little thing is this way
as if they have more knowledge about it than the,
they are online people.
I find that to be pretty faulty but,
but we sort of left the conversation there.
What do you,
what is the right amount of regulation as a,
as a Libertarian,
oh,
I'm in favor of huge amounts of regulation and I'm not being facetious.
I love regulation.
I believe the best regulator is on the market.
It's a competitive market is consumers being able to spend their money,
uh,
as they choose and or not to spend it as they choose.
It's the freedom of different,
uh,
producers and entrepreneurs to enter markets or leave markets as they choose.
It's the competition among producers.
That's where real regulation comes from.
The market regulates activities.
You're,
you're right about the they're learning instance.
Airlines for example.
Uh,
no one has a stronger incentive to make sure that a multimillion dollar piece of
machinery doesn't just willy nilly fall out of the sky.
Then the owner of that multimillion dollar piece of machinery,
namely the airlines or the company that they're there,
they're renting it from.
And so the competition among the airlines,
the,
the need for them to protect their investments.
That is a tremendous source of regulation and it's a very nuanced source of
regulations.
He gets it right.
And it's not subject to political control or political manipulation.
So governor so called government regulation is too often,
uh,
actually deregulation in the worst sense.
It's government relieving businesses of the need to be as responsive to
consumers as they would otherwise need to be.
So we,
we,
we call for example,
uh,
occupational licensing.
And that's a form of regulation.
Well,
no,
it's a form of deregulation.
It dereg it deregulates the,
uh,
existing producers in the market from having to be as responsive as they
otherwise would to consumers.
So for example,
this would be like you have to have a license to cut hair.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
And so if,
if I,
if I'm a hair braider or a barber,
uh,
or,
or an electrician,
and if this,
if the government prevents people from entering in competition with me,
that makes my life easier.
I don't have to be as responsive to consumers.
I can charge higher prices.
I could supply a less high quality services.
And so I am deregulated in fact by that,
so called regulation.
So we basically,
you would say it's the risk you have to take to be free,
right.
So that in other words,
that if you're an electrician and I have somebody come into my kitchen,
we had a little light thing the other day now.
Yes.
The guy who was licensed I guess cause there's got to be licensed.
But you're saying it's just the risk that you have to take because he doesn't
want to come in here and burn my house down and nor do you want him to do it.
Right?
Yeah.
[inaudible] this is another unintended consequence of so,
so called government regulation and that if people come to depend on it too much
there,
you just assume whoever you call up,
call up and say,
I need some electrical work done in my house.
Well,
we live in a state where electricians unregulated.
So this God must be okay.
Um,
uh,
maybe,
maybe not.
But if you knew that was up to you to check,
first of all,
the market supplies,
all of these wonderful ways of verifying a quality.
So if anyone was free to practice being an electrician,
uh,
you would have easy access.
You as a consumer,
we have easy access to various mechanisms to,
to,
to rain various electricians by how,
especially in earlier then all the apps and absolutely.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a total myth to think that the government is more concerned about our
welfare and our property.
Then we are,
who's more concerned about your house than you are,
who's more concerned about your personal safety and health?
Then you are,
uh,
the government might pretend that it's more concerned or that it's somehow has
deeper insight to what is best for you.
But I don't buy it.
Uh,
I think,
I think young children,
uh,
they're,
they don't know their interest as well as their parents do.
But once you become an adult,
the presumption must be that each of us as an adult cares for and knows our best
interests much better than any third party does reminded of something else.
Right.
And I think maybe I got too many of my old economic theories from the Simpsons
because now do you remember the episode very early on with Mr. Burns at the
power plant and he's leaking,
you know,
nuclear waste into the river and they get a three eyed fish and every,
they are whole idea being,
if you just let business do what it wants,
it's going to pollute the river and you're going to be eating three eyed fish.
But that's completely the reverse of everything you've said that.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so what,
what an economist would say to that as well,
you know,
there are some areas where uh,
your as a private citizen spill over onto a,
an innocent third party,
so they have no input.
So like reasonable people can disagree about the proper role of government in
preventing pollution or,
or preventing third party effects.
But so much regulation has nothing to do with third party affects.
It's simply to say,
you know,
if you want to get your hair braided,
uh,
you have to go to one of these people that we approve,
you're not allowed to go to that person over there,
uh,
who,
who does not yet have our approval.
Well,
there's no third party in fact here.
And a surprising amount of regulation is of that sort.
Yeah.
I mean,
I remember when I bought this house and you have to have all the people come by
and the inspectors and everything,
and they're looking for these little absurd things that I'm talking with the
builder about.
And well,
this has to be an issue this way over here and blah,
blah,
blah.
And it's like,
why?
There was no answer for it.
I mean,
a couple times I said,
well,
why is that?
And you know,
it's the regulations to regulate.
That's how it is.
I'm someone in Sacramento's said,
this is how it should be,
and that's how it is and everybody,
everybody has.
So another problem with government regulation,
uh,
is that it's one size fits all.
And I don't care how smart you are,
are,
uh,
how,
how much experience you have in the past.
Uh,
particularly in our highly dynamic,
in our highly dynamic economy,
things are always changing.
Different people have different risk tolerances.
Um,
so one of my least favorite regulators as the FDA,
uh,
there are very few third party effects with the FDA.
The FDA is,
uh,
drug regulation affects you and it prevents you in consultation if you choose
with your doctor.
And most sensible people would consult with a physician,
uh,
from choosing what level of risks you're able to subject yourself to in order to
relieve yourself of pain or to,
to,
to fend off him and a death.
I don't believe that's any bureaucrats business but yours.
You may make a decision different than differently than I do,
but so what we all have different tastes.
We all have different preferences,
preference,
we all have different tolerances.
I don't believe that it's the government's position to say,
no,
no.
Your preference for risk is too great.
We're not going to let you take this experimental drug because we think it might
hurt you.
I don't see that it's the government's business at all at your business.
Right.
And you better get as educated as possible.
I mean this is where I would say it comes down to education and,
but,
but who has a better incentive to,
to become informed and educated on the matter then you,
it's your life.
Yeah.
Right.
And uh,
uh,
yes,
you can tell stories.
Well,
you know,
maybe you won't,
but I can tell stories too.
Well,
how do you know that this bureaucrat over here is going to do as good a job?
I'm willing to bet that you are much less likely to,
to,
to be,
uh,
less careful with your life then this guy or gal is with your life.
Yeah.
All right.
So since you said it was a long game and I know how much high tech has
influenced you and you write@cafehyatt.com.
Um,
let's see,
what are the ideas of how I got,
I know we've actually explored a lot of them here,
but if there was something that,
uh,
I told you before that a lot of my audience,
they go out and they,
they get books after and they start reading on all of this.
What are some of the ideas of high tech that you'd like to impart?
That I would touch on?
That society is vastly more complex than we understand it to be particularly,
uh,
a market oriented global society.
You know,
we talk about and be terms talking about the labor market,
uh,
the amount of trade,
you know,
the,
the GDP numbers,
all these terms and numbers mask enormous underlying complexities.
All the action that makes our society work is done at the local level.
Uh,
and that,
that's a core hierarchy and insight.
And if you start acting at this at the,
at the higher level,
the risk is that that you will stamp out,
you'll,
you'll still stomp out,
you'll smother these,
uh,
individual adjustments at the local level that actually bumped,
whose consequences bubble up to the top to make it all work.
There's a great hike.
He's not the most quotable of,
of guys,
but it's a great hire quotation.
I'm not going to get it exactly right,
but it goes something like the curious task of the economist is to,
uh,
remind men of how little they know about what they imagine they can create.
Right?
So,
you know,
we can imagine Bernie Sanders imagines,
he can create a world of everybody gets paid at least $15 an hour.
Uh,
there's other people.
Imagine they can create a world in which in which no one is,
it dies because of,
you know,
a drug overdose or,
uh,
well,
you can't create that world.
It's far too complex.
And that's the,
that's the critical hierarchy.
And inside the world's really complex.
And therefore,
if it truly complex,
we want to devolve decision making authority down to the lowest possible level
and not have people who are slathered in Hubris,
uh,
making decisions for those of us on the ground.
On that note,
I think you're an excellent communicator of those ideas and that that's what
it's all about,
right.
And it's reciprocated.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
And for more on Don Checkout Cafe hyatt.com
yeah.